So what do we need to get for the party tonight?
Well, first of all we're going to need a lot of snacks.
Okay, I think they are in aisle number six.
Here we go, aisle six.
What kind of chips do you think we should get?
Let's get a variety.
How about four or five different kinds?
Sounds good.
Now we need some drinks, too.
Okay, they are in the refrigerators in the back of the store.
I guess we should get plenty of beer, plus some non - alcoholic drinks as well.
Yeah, let's get a few cases of beer.
It's not like it will go bad or anything if we don't drink it all!
Good point.
Okay, I think that about does it.
Let's go pay for all this and start getting things set up.
All right.